if you watched Donald Trump's
impeachment trial day three yesterday on
Fox News you might not have heard much
about this because they ran a lot of the
proceedings on mute running my pillow
commercials over the impeachment
proceedings or you had hosts talking
over the proceedings talking about how
hunter Biden is really what this
impeachment trial should be about but
that did not stop Donald Trump from
absolutely losing his mind and tweeting
a record for him 141 times in one day
that was only up until 6:00 p.m. and
then it continued I've told you before
when Donald Trump seemingly spends the
entire day doing nothing but tweeting
sometimes dozens of tweets once I think
he got into the 80s or 90s we didn't see
that much Twitter activity from Donald
Trump on Tuesday but I'm now realizing
that was because he was still at the
World Economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland and then travelling back
eventually yesterday he had more time
back in Washington DC and I think
sitting on Air Force One and he broke
his own personal record for tweets and
retweets in a single day tweeting 141
times by 6:00 p.m. Eastern continuing
into the night and this morning
most of the tweets are either tweets or
retweets of extremist Republican quotes
videos and statements sometimes just
absolute nonsense conspiracy theories
from Donald Trump the tweets include
Trump's and his friends attacks on the
house impeachment managers who sort of
are the prosecutors in the impeachment
trial including of course a favorite
target of Trump's is extreme anger at
Adam Schiff Trump this morning including
a mostly capitalized tirade of course a
hallmark of Trump is tweets both Trump
and his supporters are when you get set
up to tweet you turn caps lock on and
you turn spellcheck off that's how if
you're getting yourself set up to tweet
Trump is stuff you've got a disable
spellcheck and enable caps lock this
morning Donald Trump sang Attorney
General's oh I mean it's it's attorneys
general I know that Trump doesn't
Attorney General's from 21 states
are urging the Senate to reject capital
I impeachment they say the articles have
legal and factual problems and the
Democrats case sets a dangerous
historical precedent missing an
apostrophe random capitalization and
then now caps-lock engaged buckle in
folks all caps even an unsuccessful
effort to impeach the president
undermines the integrity of the 20/20
election because it weapon eise's a
process that should only be initiated in
exceedingly rare circumstances and
should never be used for partisan
purposes the Democrats are trying hard
to damage Republicans prior to the
capital e election I'm sweating now
here's what you need to understand 141
tweets by 6:00 p.m. if he started at
midnight that's 18 hours
okay 141 tweets in 18 hours is eight
tweets per hour
that's one tweet every seven and a half
minutes but that's if he's not sleeping
at all and just tweeting for 18 hours
straight if we assume that Trump tweeted
141 times starting at you know 5:00 a.m.
maybe which sounds insane to you or I
but but you know to you or me
between 5 a.m. and 6 p.m. 141 tweets
that's 11 tweets per hour meaning a
tweet every five and a half minutes it's
the President of the United States he's
sending out a tweeter retweet every five
minutes for an entire workday this
amount of tweeting isn't normal for
anyone if I look at my Twitter feed and
I see someone at messaged me five times
in an hour
I immediately mute them I don't have
time for this nonsense Trump is tweeting
141 times in a day and it's funny in a
way to see him so triggered on Twitter
it is funny to see Donald Trump at these
world events like Davos as the guy none
of the other world leaders really want
to talk to the idea of the adults are
meeting about important things and Trump
is on his phone tweeting that's a
hilarious image but it's really bad it's
an embarrassment
it's a laughingstock for the United
States I don't even have time to read a
hundred and forty one tweets in a day
and Donald Trump is sending out 100
41 tweets and retweets I expect that
this is going to get even worse once the
Republicans take over their defense of
Donald Trump in the Senate and the
reason why is that a lot of Donald Trump
Donald Trump's Twitter activity is
retweeting videos that are people saying
nice things about him or defending him
once his lawyers pat Sippel Oney and Jay
Sekulow once they take over I think
Donald Trump could potentially even
break his own record of 141 tweets and
retweets in a single day this episode is
sponsored by blue chew one of the things
I make a priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue to can increase performance and
give you that extra confidence you may
be looking for blue to calm blue like
the color blue is the first chewable
with the same fda-approved ingredient as
in Viagra and Cialis it can be taken day
or night even on a full stomach since
it's chewable it works twice as fast as
a pill whenever the opportunity arises
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed doctors you don't have to go to
a doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package they're
made in the USA and since blue two
prepares and ships direct it's cheaper
than a pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
calm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show